hello freak [ __ ] you know I got these
are handmade Lucases are they really
yeah and came use handmade they take
like 18 no there's nearly 11 days to do
to do from start to finish
weathering and stuff they do I mean they
do a different stages right but there's
I mean they're the best movie I market
and doesn't that feel different like
when you have them like there's
something knowing that a person made it
to yeah well they're just so comfortable
yeah I mean catalyst Kelly Boots
normally aren't that comfortable but
those that's what my boots were
yesterday too
yeah so nice I was reading this podcast
reading a podcast worth listening to a
podcast listening to a book I can't get
into that now about a horseback-riding
and this guy was explaining how people
try to wear like hiking boots when they
go horseback riding and jam their food
he's like there's a reason why cowboy
boots fall off so easy yeah so you don't
get dragged behind a frightened horse
yeah it's supposed to happen that way
yeah that's why they're pointed so they
slide in a night out they slide in and
slide out and they slip right off your
feet yeah yep you have it you get a good
pair of these I mean their last 10 20 of
it that's a lifetime
you know to meet they could I just
bought I got my the ones I had yesterday
which were like a thousand bucks and I
just got them resoled because I'd warned
him so much 70 70 450 okay so yeah brand
new soles on I mean brand new boot
I've heard that since you have your own
Under Armour sneaker that you're the
Kanye West of badasses this term I don't
know what that means
well there's another Kanye West of bow
hunting oh well because Kanye West has
Yeezys do you know what easy yeah issue
right yeah because Jamie buys them look
easy come on yah mahn you see my god oh
he's such a weirdo he's got like five
pairs on this weirdo Saturday no said of
a see that's what the kids are claiming
artists are use a lot like expensive
stupid expensive if you can't get them
when they come on sale they are a lot
like how much are they read of the gate
the ones that are going to resale that
come out this month every selling for
2,000 right now they're 200 retail 200
retail and they sell for mm yeah because
they make what a hundred pair like
20,000 like goddamn you can get a free
one with a Ford GT yeah so I think I've
shown you I think that's how Brandon's
reference is tidy
shoot Kanye's shoes yes that's what it
is right yeah it's not that you're an
egotistical autistic rapper well I see
him at he's at the UFC fight I don't
know I was at colony where yeah yeah I
don't know which one it was
oh yeah that's right he was there with
the boyfriend that JLo dumped because he
went to the UFC it was one of Connors
fights
oh is it that's what it was yeah the
boyfriend wanted to go to the McGregor
fight and JLo was like [ __ ] that he's
staying with me
Jaime got a picture with him did you
hear Kanye yeah here's like a river but
here's Kanye West even at the UFC fight
looks like this well I saw him smile a
few times when he met some people really
yeah but he's I need a hug I gotta smile
did you would you do not only in this
might not even picture did he yeah
what'd you do to get him to smile well
he's uh he needs hug
that's why shank needs the hugging some
good friends something to calm down I
think so yeah settle down dude let me
talk to you about your prenup got one
right that's what I would there is that
it's not smile as well smart no not
really no is that's not that's your just
the smile from Tony Hinchcliffe is bout
now why you didn't smile so he was like
why am i [ __ ] to my life history
didn't smile and you don't even happen
to meet me [ __ ] why even taking a
picture hashtag blessed at least he's
got a box on his uninsured he's got
Tubbington networker that's the best
thing about that other than Jamie and
Tony yes I agree the Tupac shirts good
move - good move
yeah here you no no no the rapper world
is a very [ __ ] strange world I can't
even imagine can't even imagine now
you
[Applause]
[Music]